anti-war protests in russia over the
past two months typically haven't lasted
long
15 000 people have been arrested under a
new law passed in early march
criminalizing public opposition to the
war in ukraine russians aren't even
allowed to call it a war instead it's a
special military operation
it's just insane situation right now
this russian high school teacher says
within days of the invasion school staff
received a crash course on a new
curriculum told to teach their students
the kremlin's preferred version of
events
about the fake news in ukraine about the
so-called nazis in the
uh
uh his side of your ukrainian uh
territory in response cameron manafly
posted this message on instagram
expressing concerns and saying i do not
want to be a mirror of state propaganda
when he refused his principal's request
to remove the post he says he was fired
and dragged out of the school by
security
after that he fled the country
getting worse day by day
we have very big troubles right now with
the freedom and that crackdown on
freedoms extends all the way up to the
elite
russian business tycoon oleg tinkov told
the new york times the kremlin forced
him to sell his stake in one of russia's
biggest banks which he founded after
this instagram post in which he
condemned putin's crazy war adding that
innocent people and soldiers are dying i
really
applaud him this former russian deputy
finance minister now in exile says many
russian business people are afraid to
speak out but fiercely oppose the war
it's
destruction of the economy economy is
demolishing and they say that okay we
we're going down and we don't know
where's the end where's the bottom this
canadian was recently added to a
fast-growing list of foreign journalists
and politicians banned from visiting
russia for criticizing the kremlin
things are not going
as planned for vladimir putin in ukraine
so that domestic repression that
repression of any sort of criticism has
only intensified over the past two
months and i suspect that it will only
get worse the worse the war goes for
russia he says the more desperate and
dangerous its president will become
jeff semple global news toronto